الجبال الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
تشكل منظرًا صحراويًا
وقاع المحيط القديم
[موسيقى]
على طول هذه السلسلة الجبلية التي تمتد
حوالي 800 كيلومتر من الأردن إلى
وسط المملكة العربية السعودية هو جبل فيورين
أو كما هو معروف حافة العالم
موقع يمكن للسائحين الدوليين أن
يجدوا أنفسهم فيه واقفين على صخور غير مستقرة
مستوحاة ومنومة مغناطيسيًا من الأفق
اللامتناهي،
الرجل الذي يقود الطريق هو المرشد السياحي المحلي
فيصل المشاري
هنا كانت تحت الماء كل هذه المنطقة
كانت تحت الماء
وكانت جزءًا من المحيط الهندي
هنا كان مثل الشلالات هنا
كان هناك الكثير من الأشجار في الواقع
كان رائعًا
هنا كانت خضراء
ولكننا نتحدث عن مليون سنة
مضت ولكنها تغيرت مع الزمن
[موسيقى]
لذلك سنبدأ  الرحلة من هنا حتى
المحطة الأولى هناك نعم دعنا نذهب
وفقًا لمنظمة السياحة العالمية التابعة للأمم المتحدة
منذ إصدار أول تأشيرة سياحية إلكترونية
في عام 2019، أصبح قطاع السفر والسياحة في المملكة العربية السعودية هو
الأسرع
نموًا في المنطقة ويأمل في
استقبال 100 مليون شخص  زوار
المملكة قبل عام 2030. لقد أدى تدفق
السياح إلى تحويل ما كان
هواية لفيصل إلى عمل بدوام كامل،
استثمرت الحكومة الكثير
في السياحة وأعتقد أن هناك
مستقبل جيد للسياحة هنا بدأنا
الشركة في عام 2018  نأخذ من خمسة إلى عشرة
أشخاص فقط يوم الجمعة،
وبعد بضعة أسابيع تبدأ الأعداد في
الارتفاع إلى 50 شخصًا،
والآن نقوم بتشغيل رحلات يومية
لأكثر من 200 شخص أسبوعيًا من
كل مكان في العالم معظمهم من ألمانيا
والمملكة المتحدة وسويسرا
والتقيت بالكثير من  الأشخاص الذين يقودون سياراتهم من
أوروبا إلى السعودية لم أفكر أبدًا في أن الأمر
سيكون ناجحًا، لدي أكثر
من 25 شخصًا يعملون معي، لقد
بدأت فقط لإظهار أصدقائي ليس
للعمل ولكن الآن تغير
الكثير من الأشياء في حياتي
مرحبًا
بالعجب  نواصل التخييم
طوال الليل تحت المناظر الطبيعية المرصعة بالنجوم،
التقينا هنا على النار ونقوم بطهي
طبقنا التقليدي من معكرونة الكابسا التي نستمتع بها،
ونستمتع بتناول الطعام تحت النجوم،
ونتجمع حول النار ونصنع
الأطعمة معًا،
هذا هو لحم كاميلا مع المعكرونة،
هذه الإرادة  كن حارًا بعض الشيء ولكنه جيد،
أوصي بالتخييم في السعودية
نحو المتاجر خاصة في أغسطس
وسبتمبر حيث يمكنك رؤية أفضل
منظر لمجرة درب التبانة
[موسيقى] لفيصل
بغض النظر عن مدى سرعة
تطور البلاد وهدوء
هذا الأمر  المناظر الطبيعية لن تتغير أبدًا
[موسيقى]
أقضي معظم وقتي في الطبيعة وأذهب
إلى الصحراء في الجبال وأفكر
كم أنا محظوظ لرؤية هذا المنظر
والاستمتاع بهذا الهدوء استمتع
بالصمت أشعر بالارتباط بالهواء
النقي الطبيعي  الصمت الذي لا نسمع فيه
أي ضجيج من المدينة
قاموا ببناء مسارات الجمال حولها
لإيقاظ الجبال، ويستخدمون مسارات الجمال
هنا لجلب البضائع من مكة إلى جدة
ومن جدة إلى الرياض، لذا سأريكم الكثير من
مسارات المشي لمسافات طويلة هنا
الجبال بأكملها، لقد شرحت أن
تاريخ الجبال سيأخذنا
ربما كيلومترين إلى ثلاثة كيلومترات،
وكان التعرف على تاريخ المملكة العربية السعودية أحد
الأسباب التي دفعت الفرنسي طوروس سعيد أبو إلى
تمديد فريضة الحج إلى مكة،
المشهد مذهل لم أكن
أتوقع ذلك في المملكة العربية السعودية
وخاصة بالقرب من الرياض، فهو ضخم ولا
يمكنك الشعور به في الصور
من خلال التمرير على الإنترنت، يجب أن تكون
هنا لتشعر بضخامة المكان،
فهو هائل
وشديد الانحدار،
إنه منظر مذهل لدينا هنا
خاصة عند غروب الشمس
حيث تتخلل الصلاة النهاية  من اليوم،
هناك وقت للتأمل في
الفجر الجديد الذي يبزغ في جميع أنحاء المملكة العربية
السعودية. ستكون المملكة العربية السعودية في مقدمة
الوجهات حول العالم
للجميع. لدينا كل شيء هنا، لدينا
جبال جميلة، لدينا
طقس جميل، حلوى جميلة
هناك.  هناك الكثير من التغيير هنا في المملكة العربية
السعودية وهو أمر جيد خاصة بالنسبة
للشباب، فنحن متفائلون جدًا بالمستقبل
ونحن مستعدون للمستقبل.